c'était la réunion de la dernière chance
hier soir pour les syndicats qui
espérait infléchir la position de
l'inspection académique sur la carte
scolaire d'Indre-et-Loire en vain ce
sont bien 40 classes qui fermeront l'an
prochain pour 19 ouverture le directeur
académique nous répond ce soir bonsoir
Christian madele bonsoir vous êtes
directeur académique donc des services
de l'éducation nationale en
Indre-et-Loire 40 fermeture 19 ouverture
vous nous confirmez qu'il s'agit bien là
de la carte scolaire définitive et qu'il
y aura aucun changement d'ici la rentrée
il y aura des changements d'ici la
rentrée il y a une phase d'ajustement
qui est prévue au mois de juin je sens
je vais simplement corriger ce que vous
venez de dire 40 fermetures 19 ouverture
de classe et il y a aussi 10 ouvertures
de postes pour le handicap les élèves a
besoin particuliers et aussi pour le
remplacement on va revenir sur sur
l'handicap effectivement donc ça peut
encore bouger ce que c'est pas donné aux
espoir aux parents réversible c'est à
dire que ça doit ça peut bouger en juin
et en septembre parce qu'on boit
toujours à la fin de l'année dans
certaines écoles un afflux imprévu
d'élève donc on peut prononcer une
mesure d'ajustement au mois de juin ou
au mois de septembre est-ce que vous
avez des effectifs d'enseignants
justement pour ajuster cette carte
scolaire bien sûr toujours chaque année
un ajustement se fait alors il est à la
marge il n'est pas aussi important que
ce que l'on prépare lors des réunions
effectivement comme celle d'hier c'est
évident mais on peut ajuster énormément
de parents mobilisés encore cette année
contre ces fermetures on peut citer ceux
de champ sèche château-la-valère encore
sachez il parle d'une logique comptable
il manque parfois trois élèves pour
maintenir une classe et et c'est classe
qui reste voit leurs effectifs et bien
augmenter avec parfois des triple
niveaux à ses parents inquiets que leurs
enfants en difficulté n'est plus la même
qualité d'encadrement vous répondez quoi
alors d'abord les rassurer ce n'est pas
un exercice seulement comptable
l'exercice comptable il accompagne une
baisse de la population scolaire nous
perdons plus de 750 élèves en septembre
et 750 élèves en moins ça des
ajustements et une répartition des
moyens plus équitable sur le territoire
- trois élèves parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez la baisse est très importante et
il faut pouvoir accompagner aussi une
baisse de dotation et des situations
aussi où finalement la population ne
bouge pas beaucoup donc il y a moins
d'enseignants
vu la baisse démographique donc on doit
rendre des postes c'est une logique
effectivement budgétaire et ensuite on
réorganise les choses mais il faut que
les parents se rassurent d'abord le taux
d'encadrement moyen dans le département
il va baisser à la rentrée prochaine il
sera de 22.3 d'accord alors qu'il était
de 22.4 exactement il était de 22.4
cette année donc ça veut dire que
l'exercice de la carte scolaire
globalement il est réussi et on a
regardé au cas par cas toutes les
situations pour que les répartitions
pédagogiques soient tenables dans des
classes les professeurs des écoles
savent gérer des niveaux différents des
tranches d'âge différentes c'est dans
leur savoir-faire ils savent le faire et
on certains n'y sont pas prêts on a eu
des échos voilà prêt à demander une
mutation parce que trop d'élèves parce
que des triples niveaux c'est compliqué
des tripes au niveau ce n'est pas
compliqué pour un professeur des écoles
un professeur des écoles et les mêmes
formé pour parent de prendre en charge
des classes uniques ça arrive dans la
haute montagne on peut avoir des
situations où les professeurs sont avec
une seule place pour plusieurs niveaux
c'est tout à fait possible certains
parents élus sont pas d'accord sur la
méthodologie cette cas par exemple à
l'école de la vallée du lac à
Château-la-Vallière on estime qu'il y
aura plus d'enfants que prévu et par
conséquent vous l'évoquez la fermeture
de classe des pas justifiée c'est un
problème de méthode eux parle d'oubli
d'enfants dans les lobberrations de
cette carte scolaire non on a un service
statistique d'abord on travaille avec
des bases de l'Insee on travaille avec
un service statistique très fiable qui
chaque année montre que nous avons
raison dans les prévisions comme je vous
l'ai dit quand on n'a pas raison par
exemple on a eu des réfugiés Ukrainiens
en nombre dans certains endroits on
pouvait pas le prévoir où on a par
exemple des livraisons de logements
massives sur certaines communes
à la marge on peut effectivement ajuster
en juin et en septembre en revanche par
tout ailleurs si on regarde bien on ne
se trompe pas dernière question sur les
enfants handicapés scolarisés dans ce
qu'on appelle les
Ulis ces classes adaptées tous non pas
la chance d'en bénéficier des
améliorations sont-elles prévues alors
nous créons des unités
d'inclusion chaque année nous allons
encore ouvrir deux Ulis à la rentrée
prochaine une en collège une en école on
en a ouvert près d'une vingtaine depuis
les 10 dernières années donc on continue
effectivement d'ouvrir ces classes et
encore des enfants qui sont en liste
d'attente il y a aussi des enfants qui
sont en Ulysse aujourd'hui qui devraient
être en ITEP ou en IME donc on centaine
de sur les attentes aujourd'hui sur Les
Ulis s'ils sont une centaine
effectivement en liste d'attente ce qui
est plutôt alors c'est jamais
satisfaisant mais c'est plus que ce qui
est plutôt un bon chiffre au niveau
national merci beaucoup Christian Mindy
en directeur académique des services de
communication nationale
sur notre plateau